fifty-five and fit how do you do it do
you wake up every day and say God I'm
looking better and better every day do
you talk to yourself in the mirror with
a pep-talk what do you do well you're
very sweet to say that but honestly it's
it's a lot of years of I think making
some very good choices
you know I first of all I been sober for
28 years
that helps I've been sort of living the
Atkins lifestyle for you know since in
my mid-30s which is you low carbs you
know higher protein no sugar and I'm a
workout maniac I mean you don't want to
talk to me in the morning before I've
worked out around that coffee oh you're
just a different I got I gotta get my
adrenaline in my cap so you do Atkins
workout maniac is that workout like a
daily game of golf though cuz we know
you're an avid golfer I don't consider
golf a workout okay I'm just gonna go
out there and put out a very bold
concept I don't consider it a workout a
lot of men use it as an excuse so I'm
going to go workout and they're working
at them look it's a good workout for
your mind and your concentration okay
unless you're carrying your bag and
walking and then god bless you and
that's a bridge too far for even me I'd
rather be on my peloton for 10 hours
than carrying a golf bag around now I
think I saw that you got your wife to
start playing tennis oh yeah she played
she tried to play golf but you didn't go
very well it was not great not it did
not go very well she's very very
talented in many many areas and I'd love
her dearly but she needs to stop golfing
okay which I would imagine did did she
take that criticism well she's probably
you know what I didn't really want to do
it I think to spite me she's gonna keep
learning okay she's really good at
tennis I've gotten really good at that
well I know you play golf a lot with
your pal Chris Pratt yeah I've seen his
getting really good is he is he coming
up on you I think we're a really good
battle I've seen Katherine has played
with him so I was thinking maybe you
guys could double-date but now he is are
you third-wheeling with them I'm always
through wheeling with everyone I'm a
professional thirty what how does that
happen to you this is my lot in life
yeah no I I don't think Katherine's
Payne is up to snuff so I don't really
need to worry about that it's still a
guy it's it it's a guys escape still
what kind of trash talk are you and
Pratt doing out there on the course
we're so evenly matched there's not a
lot of trash talk what my son is
involved here OC was so hard o my sons
I've raised two internet trolls right so
how this has happened to me how did that
happen it was a really doting loving
father you seem so nice I don't know
what's going on can you give it love
giving tonight but have they taught you
how to give it back to them are they
almost like dad here's how you can
insult me in retirement bring myself now
we have kind of a dream casting thing
the Saint almost fire reboot is
happening in the version I heard this or
do you have any scoop for me who's in it
do we know well we were sort of thinking
John could be in it I only know this
they tried to do a reboot of about last
night and they could not find young me
or young to me or young Elizabeth
Perkins so they they want a whole
different way and it was like Kevin Hart
yeah so I think the same will be in
store for who knows I'll be the first
one to see it though you will so you'll
watch it but do you think and it's hard
to capture that my son Johnny would draw
the line at playing me he wouldn't do it
ain't no Andrew McCarthy ah he would
play hell how do you feel about the
reboot though just because crazy yeah I
mean 35th anniversary next year I mean
there's been a big anniversary year that
West Wing was 20 already that feels like
yesterday it's we're getting to that how
do you feel about looking back on that
time I mean what did that movie mean - I
know that's such a big question but if
you look back at the impact on it oh man
well you know it was all of those movies
were really we didn't know it at the
time but they were kind of the start of
the modern entertainment industry where
every movie every big movie now is
really targeted to
you know young people yeah you know that
was an era where that was kind of a side
business and you still had terms of
endearment mm-hmm like which came out I
think at the same years st. Elmo's fire
right targeting a very different very
different yeah yeah it was ahead of its
time in that way but I look back on it
and laugh the hair mousse and the styles
but it's funny to see how many shows
influences when I watch stranger things
I definitely see you know callbacks to
say almost fire it was a great it was a
great time to be alive and eighties were
fun what I can remember of them and you
know of course everybody's talking about
Demi's book here she has a book yeah
have you been at her talking about it or
hearing about it a little bit a little
bit about it I mean it's a beautiful
thing that she said was that the cast of
st. Elmo's fire saved her life in many
ways and I just wondered if you look
back on that what do you think you did
that was so important for her
I'm that's that's nice to hear you know
I what I think what the reason that that
movie in the read she talks about it it
has stickiness for people is that you
can tell we were all really good friends
and we all really cared about each other
and that we were a gang and that's what
we played on screen and and I think it
really was captured and and I think
people relate to it's like it's the same
thing as friends I was like you know
they loved each other and they did the
same is true for seeing almost fire whoo
hey wait a minute we were friends before
friends sit down
more more even ground breaking have you
guys stayed in touch much will you do
anything for the big anniversary next
year I don't know I don't know is there
something planned that I need to know
about well we could plan something I
think you might somehow I think you guys
might do that
it's as if et loves an anniversary same
thing yeah I can't imagine that I would
imagine that group meant a lot to you as
well what did it mean for you to have
that group at that time it was fun I
mean we're all I mean grow all of those
guys you know it felt like we were all
very much in
same place in our lives all very
ambitious all looking to the future and
wondering what the future would have I
look at my sons who are exactly the same
age now that I was when I made there
over my sons are older now than I was
when I made son almost five it's insane
you were a baby and and so I look at
them and I go wow this is what I looked
like on the outside because on the
inside I felt really really different
and I know and I wouldn't have portrayed
myself as such a young little puppy but
clearly I was that's good let's talk a
little bit about your new show you are
playing a cop Barbara your plan B Arthur
are you doing research with the real
people who do that work how you public
well so um Ryan Murphy and I have been
trying to find a project to work
together since nip/tuck and nip/tuck was
one of my favorite shows ever so much so
that when I watched it I said I want to
meet this guy Ryan Murphy and I met with
him and I told him how much I loved the
epic talk any kind of went white face
you know and my agents never gave me the
script are you still working with them I
am NOT that happens in Hollywood yeah
under time there's reasons for it but
but since then I've never been available
when he's had something for me so
finally we have 9/11 one lone star and I
am so excited it's everything I thought
it would be it's heroic and it's action
filled and Brad Falchuk who's one of the
producers of it describes it he says
it's shocked and oh well Ryan Murphy and
Brad they do some intense projects is is
this gonna be a bit more of a darker
project for you
it is it's the current 9-1-1 which I'm a
big fan of it is killing it this year as
always our iteration of it is is
slightly darker slightly funnier it's it
is more in the vein of an up
talk so I'm finally getting to do my
version of me but instead of a plastic
surgeon I'm a first responder I touch
more noble babies like Ryan Murphy says
I want you to play heroic fireman who
cares a lot about boys rising his skip
do you moisturize regularly in your own
life I've my own skin care white
girlfriend
profile for man by it
[Music]